coffee is a big part of Arabic culture
it plays a role in rituals marriage
proposals and even unsettling disputes
that is making specialty coffee more
appealing this convention in qatar's
capital is proof with hundreds of coffee
Growers producers and Distributors
looking to expand their business in the
Middle East we wanted to emphasize that
traditional coffee will always be there
and this is important and this is what
we are trying to do here that something
is different than what you see in Europe
or what you see is actually in Asia
for sale coffee is a family business his
father founded the biggest coffee
distribution Factory in Qatar they roast
more than a ton of coffee beans a day
sourcing it from across continents
Brazil Salvador Panama also in Asia
we're talking about Indonesia we're
talking about also the Yemen Ethiopia
Uganda Kenya well it takes just a few
minutes to drink but the production
process behind this cup of coffee takes
about five years from growing the plant
to collecting the beans and shipping the
product and every day about three
billion cups of coffee are consumed
around the globe
buy this one or this one yeah
auxiliadora Bonilla is from Costa Rica
she's among more than 100 million
families who depend on the industry
during Harvest time they rely on
temporary workers from the area and
others who travel from Panama and
Nicaragua
drinking a cup of coffee takes you on a
journey hundreds of people from
different walks of life play a role in
bringing it to life from the coffee
fields to the coffee tables
there is a big push to make sure Arabic
coffee and the culture that comes with
it is not pushed out by big chains we
try our best to make the Next Generation
and the next of this generation to have
a more knowledge about it's not just a
drink it's a tradition a tradition
that's merging with specialty coffee
reflecting change perhaps beyond the
flavor in a cup
all right very short break here on Al
Jazeera
make sure to subscribe to our channel to
get the latest news from Al Jazeera